alright let's dive in our first scrips
is princess vietnam by erin chung in
19th princess vietnam in 1980 a lonely
Vietnamese girl befriends and falls in
love with an imaginative Irish girl as
they confront racial prejudice in their
small town after a fiery incident fable
and Aisling our two young lovers are
forced to split apart fabled struggling
with her disapproving mother and Ashley
going into hiding ever since fable
professed her love
Aisling is feeling doubt in their
relationship wanting some distance fable
awaits a phone call from Aisling a
connection after days of silence
interior Sue's house kitchen continuous
fable prepares dinner for herself
putting rice in a bowl in pouring
lukewarm soup in another interior room
continuous fable eats alone the phone
rings fable drops everything to answer
it hello intercut with interior
dilapidated apartment complex Lobby
night
Aisling is that one of the payphones she
takes to the corner were an abandoned
doll a raggedy cat with both eyes
missing lace crumpled hey princess hi
fable can barely contain her joy how's
the other side it's going and your mom
fable holds her breath she listens
intently for any signs of her mother
just in case she pulls the phone closer
to her lips and speaks in a hushed voice
she's fine
that's good both girls are at a loss for
words searching for the next thing to
say how's my cousin treating you Oh
he's been cool with me so far Wilma - I
never really spoke to her before she
kind of reminds me of my mom yeah
she asked about you what'd you tell her
just that you need some space I didn't
mention them you know good girl
another tense silence I saw your dad hey
sling
Aisling his face drops oh [ __ ] he came
to the theater
he misses you Ashley he tell you that no
but he just looks I don't know sad
he just looks really sad did he mention
all the Vietnamese he gunned down -
Ashley you don't know my dad do you
Ashley stiffens her knuckles crack how
can you even say that you didn't see him
people takes a moment she's considering
her own words what she's saying about
Bill she stands firm you didn't see him
I saw him plenty a beat table takes her
breath I'm sorry Ashley
I'm just telling you what happened okay
Aisling softens swallowing her anger I'm
sorry - table checks for her mother
again hey what can I ask you something
shoot did you really ask me to leave
because you needed space
Ashley knows the answer but she doesn't
want to say it I do fable why do I have
the feeling it's something else
Ashley takes a deep breath there's no
avoiding it she knew this was coming
people don't think it's you you did
nothing wrong
what are you saying I'm I'm getting to
it it's too [ __ ] hard it's something
you said what did I say the night before
we left you said these words and I don't
know what I was supposed to say back
Fable tries to
recall that night is flooding back to
her she shuts her eyes I said I love you
beat ya fable clinches the phone hating
herself ready to bang her head against
the wall Ashley I'm so sorry I didn't I
was don't know it's like I said it's me
you did nothing wrong no but I did I did
god I'm so stupid I don't think I I
don't know if I'm fable can't bring
herself to lie
can I just take it back Ashley bites
down on her lip you can't
I mean you shouldn't papal swallows her
tears even on the phone she's trying to
regain her composure firm strong no
matter what Aisling on the other hand
rattles the payphone yeah okay then I
guess that's that right people I want to
be with you I do but I don't know if I
can feel that same thing yet fables eyes
water yeah I get it
I do they do that word it's poison to me
it's okay hazing really but it's not
your fault I know married you
Aisling forces of laughs through her
tears I must sound like a broken [ __ ]
record the fabled Merce musters up a
smile but it falls quick your fable cut
short because she knows they've reached
the end
stay safe Ashley Ashley wants to say
something else it's right on the tip of
her tongue but she knows better yeah you
too princess fable hangs up first end
intercut she stands by the phone her
dinners getting cold behind her the
whole house is a hollow shell
she grips her mouth tight she can't let
her tears escape she refuses just around
the corner on leans against the wall her
head pointed towards the dining room
table whether or not she's been there
the whole time it's clear that her
little girl is in great pain
[Applause]